this is the NASSCOM - this is a computer
that not the computer but the same kind
of computer there's some first machine
that I actually saw and had the
opportunity to play with slightly
different the one that I had or had
access to have it was in the made in the
box and you can see the board's inside
and you can see the LEDs blinking as the
different operations occur but this
one's been made in a proper plastic case
and looks a little bit more professional
than large using but the thing is you
never see two Ness cons really looking
the same we've got I don't know how many
half a thousand machines less comms and
none of them at the same some of them
were in wooden boxes we really clutched
together with some dodgy keyboard other
ones are in nice cases others are just
the bare boards they were just made to
you know get them working and that was
about it
this one was working we had it on
display and Jeremy was doing to talk
about this particular line of machines
and how things progressed and said that
people sort of made these machines
themselves they work it for machines and
that some of them didn't work and just
after he said it didn't work because
he'd taken the lid off and shut it
closed it down again walked on and it
went bang and it didn't work and the
reason for that is we've got quite a
college of things in here so again this
is a little bit like the out there this
is something a machine that you sort of
built and then you modified you crew
made it better
so underneath the hood here we've got a
whole mess of stuff and what happened
was where we had it connected out to the
monitor of our composit video when the
case come down again we made a short
supply out so the power supply over
here's got a nice little burn mark where
it took it out so it's got to fix that
and they'll be okay but yeah so you've
got the original board which is under
there
it has a 48 K memory expansion on it and
then on here we've got some a color
video adapter on it to actually give an
S con color which is quite amazing so
yeah that's her and that's gone - is
that a T based and they were actually
again pretty pretty impressive machines
for the time I used to play a game on it
called keys of crawl kind of this sword
& Sworcery game you go around the maze
and collect the elixirs and kill the
monsters and stuff but just to have this
stuff on this little tiny black and
white screen a little bit up this one
here was amazing
was like I at the time hadn't really
seen anything else
letting very shortly after I made my dad
bought us a grandstand pong thing and it
was brilliant but that was the first I
saw and it was seeing computers
controlling TVs or screens it sounds
crazy really hard to get this across to
anybody that didn't experience at the
time but it was like the new thing I
though completely revolutionary so to
have this computer screen controlled by
me my character was moving where I
wanted to go and then you know he showed
me a little bit about how to load the
operating systems and things like this
was just mind-blowing
yeah this is about 77 I think I got
access to it in about 78 maybe seventy
nine something like that and yeah and
again it was sort of the domain of
enthusiasts electronics engineers people
that had the ability to put this stuff
together quite a few people tried that
didn't have those skills and failed you
know you end up paying quite a lot of
money for these machines you know these
these were several hundred pound to buy
ink it full and yeah and end up with a
big box of nothing and that's try and
find somebody else we could try repair
it for them but these things were for me
the very dawn of a ol and you know set
me on a trajectory at the end of it yeah
that's what I did with my vic-20
later on yeah and they hated me for it
because it was getting in the way of
whatever it was Poldark at the time or
whatever it was either and and and I was
getting grumpy because I couldn't use my
computer when they were watching the
things they wanted to watch yeah it was
it was one TV my uncle had vo their TV
downstairs in the Edit in his own room
with his monitor this was big-time stuff
it's great
most people that time didn't have that
kind of luxury it was Dulles or the
computer yeah basically
I mean she finds out that her Danny go
for the computer every time but but the
rest of the family didn't quite see it
that way
but but yeah I mean you end up getting
those little black and white portable
TVs that become your money so so for
things like the same things you want
here we've got the black and white
portable on that and it's kind of a bit
fuzzy and ragging around the edges but
it was usable they were the monitors of
choice I suppose for most people in
their home computers so quite a few of
us had home computers of color really
only so black and white for most of the
time because we were relegated to the
dining room and and a little black and
white telly but but hey at least you
still had your computer you could do
what you wanted to do he thought he
might sell a few of them but ended up
selling huge numbers of them - it's a
bunch of computer enthusiasts basically
and actually not so much computer
enthusiasts they were at that time their
electronics enthusiasts they didn't know
they were computers enthusiasm till this
thing I hear so beginners purpose
symbolic instruction code I've got a
feeling that was kind of retrofitted to
the way basic run the other way